26 voix pour 4 blanc et 2 contres
marie-christine le tarnec est depuis
mardi 15 novembre la nouvelle maire
socialiste de guyancourt l'ancienne élue
en charge notamment des finances succède
à françois de ligne et qu'ils avaient
décidé début octobre de passer le relais
après 14 ans à la tête de la commune ému
au moment de prendre la parole françois
de ligne et restera tout de même
conseiller municipal et communautaire
jusqu'en 2020 mes premiers mots c'est
pour dire que j'ai effectivement
beaucoup d'émotion c'est un passage de
relais
un passage de relais qui se passe bien
comme je l'avais dit je reste dans
l'équipe je resterai aussi conseiller
communautaire mais vous le voyez ma
christine mènera le projet de ville avec
une équipe dynamique
je serai jusqu'à 2020 dans cette équipe
et c'est donc avec beaucoup de sérénité
que je peux participer à a
c'est moi qui sont et ses années qui
sont devant nous pour l'occasion benoît
hamon député ps et catherine tasca
sénatrice socialiste avait fait le
déplacement plus d'une centaine
d'habitants également des habitants que
la nouvelle maire a tenu à rassurer son
mandat sera celui de la continuité
j'ai été élu sur une liste depuis 2014
donc maintenant je suis maire
effectivement au milieu du monde ah mais
j'ai participé à la liste de françois de
ligne et on a été élu pour un mandat
effectivement de 6 ans avec un projet de
ville et je vais respecter les
engagements qui ont été pris devant les
aiglons pour toi et on va les tenir
l'opposition municipale elle a tenu à
saluer l'engagement de françois de ligne
et durant 14 ans l'élection d'un nouveau
maire signifie également de nouvelles
relations avec la majorité
c'est évident que cette démission doit
aussi nous permettre de relancer de
relancer les échanges de relancer les
discussions avec avec l'exécutif
je proposerai à marie christine staniec
peut-être de se voir
afin de pouvoir discuter en effet de
bien des quatre années qui viendront
jusqu'en 2020 marie-christine le tarnais
que devra également composer avec
quelques remous au sein de sa majorité
municipale les quatre élus écologistes
n'ont ainsi pas pris part au vote lors
de son élection